despite the intensive global efforts to
find a vaccine for covid19
scientists have still been working on
ways to defeat other diseases
like here at liverpool university where
they've been trying to find a treatment
for the rare genetic condition our
captainuria or aku
sometimes known as black bone disease
the disc should be white and it's
actually just jet black the pigment you
can see
in these ligaments and bone fragments is
caused by aku and can lead to
osteoarthritis
but the team here have developed a
preventative medicine from an unlikely
source
the the molecule was first developed as
a weed killer
and during the testing of that molecule
it was shown to have
effects on something called tyrosine
metabolism
and so about 15 years ago we started
to investigate aku
in liverpool and we wanted to see if we
could repurpose
this molecule mutinone
sharon crean has aku and has been taking
the tisinone for eight years as part of
the clinical trials
it can't reverse the arthritis that
caused her to have both shoulders and
one
hip replaced but it has slowed down the
deterioration
now it looks like i'm going to have to
have a knee replaced
because it's becoming more and more
painful but it was a much slower process
than i thought it would be
i thought it'd be much faster happening
because of
what i have my condition julian ciro was
diagnosed with aku
20 years ago his brother daniel got the
same diagnosis
three years later since then their
father has dedicated his life to
campaigning
and fundraising to help find a cure it's
finally paid off
it's really difficult to get a drug
license and to get one approved
particularly at such a level and
particularly for such a rare genetic
disease so
i kind of thought well that's that's one
big step in the right direction you know
so now that it's licensed we need to
make sure that everybody
across europe across the world who has
aku can have access to the drug
he's been insanely motivated
and something i appreciate as well is
that he keeps us up to date on
the progress of things as well and so um
so even though i'm on a treatment now
like i'm aware of the next steps like
what the aku society is pushing for
as well as helping the 30 000 or so
people with aku
the research has shown that the drug
that came from a weed killer
could also help treat arthritis and some
heart diseases
fraser moored sky news liverpool